i don't know man we need like a moral
compass we need like some sort of i
don't know if it's a man like jordan
peterson was great about
giving young men purpose and and
cleaning your room and taking care of
yourself
first and then women will be attracted
to you if you take care of yourself
maybe maybe this will result in people
becoming more religious
yeah or redefining religion too because
you know
buddhism is an interesting religion i
think like maybe there will be a new
religion
a new like yeah it's called it's called
and the democrats have adopted
it hopefully there's a better one than
that like peterson was on to something
he's a prophet
that guy's that guy's he could be
canonized in the future i think but
what's what's his
ideology you know just taking
individualism hard work
yeah it's very conservative i mean i'm
not saying he's a conservative but right
he's not very conservative but he has
speaks conservative morals
but oh he's very liberal yeah young
people aren't getting married anymore
they're not having kids so so what
happens
you know matthew iglesias for vox wrote
this article i guess i think it was him
called like the case for one billion
americans and then he like did an
interview with glenn beck
and people started attacking him for it
but he made a really good point that
we need more americans you know i don't
i don't know if he was making an
argument for immigration
or just people having more babies but he
was like
the biggest problems we have with
competing with these other countries
particularly china
is that they have a massive population
three more than three times like almost
four times the u.s
and so there needs to be way more
americans who hold american values and
and you know these these like
constitutional republic and liberal
democratic values otherwise you'll end
up with a globe dominated by people who
don't have those values
unless you want to you know dominate by
force i guess
yeah you can either be more influential
by like having the americans have like
10 000
followers on youtube for every chinese
guy that has like 1 000 so you've got a
10 to 1
influence ratio there or you can have 10
times as many people so like
there's different ways to influence the
globe but if you just
if he's making the case for more
immigration if you're just bringing
people in from everywhere
then they're not going to have the same
ideals right
i don't i don't know if he was
specifically saying immigration
but that's why having a system like
i don't know if if you guys have ever
seen the game if you can call it a game
life genesis
no you know this there's a symbol that
the the
hacker community the hacker symbol is
called the glider and
it's a reference to i don't know if the
game is called life genesis i think i
think it is
it's a simple algorithm where lights
turn on and off
and it's like simulating if the
algorithm you know ideals are met then
it expands and grows and like develops
more life and stuff like
that and the reason i bring this up is
there's there's a version of it that i
used to have on windows when i was a kid
where it had two different colors and if
you have a big mass of blue dots popping
into and out of existence and you put a
small handful of red into it
they just turn blue but if you flood it
with
like 50 percent red then they start
battling and then start changing and
then
one side wins and decides destroyed and
if you obviously have more red
or just keep firing you know the red
dots the blue ones eventually evaporate
so if these people really do believe
that equality
and equity are good things then they
want to make sure to
preserve the american system because i
don't think there's any other country on
the planet say
like outside of uh specifically european
countries in america
outside of these these specific areas
massive populations of the world
that are what six six or seven times
bigger than europe and the us do not
have these values
so if if these values end up getting
lost due to
just carelessness you know i'm not
saying like any one thing
like if no one cares about upholding
these values they won't exist
and that's it they're gone and if
they've forgotten we were talking about
that a couple nights ago with sheamus
like storing our our information for the
future generations how will it be stored
and i thought maybe it will be stored in
orbit maybe there will be a
why orbit because maybe there'll be a
firestorm on the on the surface and then
we'll need to somehow remember
you know our past like 12 800 years ago
there's a flood and
like everything was white that atlantis
was lost all this civilization and all
the morals and teachings from that time
were basically washed away
assuming those things were real yeah
assuming that the flood was real but it
seems to be you know according to race
carlson and other geologists there's
there's like yeah the flood
myth like exists in a bunch of different
cultures that's kind of crazy yeah and
then wasn't it who was that guy on joe
rogan who was talking about how the
sphinx is actually older
it could have been graham hancock or
randall carlson they worked together and
he was graham hancock
he was saying like the sphinx is
actually way older than we realized
robert shock also because it has it
shows signs of water damage yeah dude
when there was a lot of rain
yeah in north africa yeah before the
flood i think that's a lot of ocean sand
on in africa apparently if you look at
google maps and you zoom in on the west
coast of africa and you look
you can see that it looks like it was a
wave pushed all that
stuff onto the continent that's where
they think atlantis is
yeah on the eye of the sahara right
exactly in the rickhardt structure
right exactly i don't know if that's
true and i'm not plato's
measurements almost exactly it's like 28
kilometers
in diameter and it's got the the it's
got the the erosion where the waterfalls
would have been and all that stuff oh
yeah it's amazing
yeah i i read something though debunking
that or at least purporting to debunk it
i'd like to believe those things are
true but i don't know i'd like to go
like
you know what man i i was kind of
thinking about this is kind of crazy
we had uh sheamus uh coughlin from
freedom tunes on do you know freedom
tunes
no you do not know freedom tunes uh
and he's he's uh religious you know he's
very he's catholic right he's highly
catholic yeah very catholic
and i started thinking about a lot of
things he said about catholicism and i
started thinking about this quote about
similism
you know what symbolism is and it's like
someone said
simulation theory is just religion for
nerds and i'm like it really is like
basically the same thing and you can
really find analogs between religion and
this idea of simulation
it's just i don't know one doesn't seem
as magical
than you know and it kind of explains it
so what if that's really what it is once
we start understanding how computers
work and how quantum physics work
and without understanding that it all
may be a simulation all we've really
done is re-explained what religion was
saying the whole time or i should
specifically
like abrahamic religions were saying the
whole time keck's an interesting
you know point along that that thought
because it's
it just came out of nowhere you know
keck l-o-l-l-l but it means a frog god
yeah
dude can you can you try and look that
up there's this whole rabbit hole there
it's so crazy dude it will blow your
mind
like there were posts on 4chan where
they were like donald trump will get
elected and the whole
uh code that was it called the trip code
was all sevens
like the like just ridiculous things
were happening they were like wheels at
all sevens appearing people were like
what like that's a lottery ticket that's
like
there's a whole bunch of crazy stuff
about this
i yeah but but everything now is like
about kekkistan or whatever yeah
so it's not really a documentary it's
just like a video explaining kek and
meme magic try typing that in
what's the oh we're gonna say they uh
they just put one out too
about um the artist who created pepe
and i didn't want to be sympathetic
towards them but then i was like man
this guy just wants to draw frogs
and then he's got the adl coming after
him i think he sued the wrong people
yeah but who did he steal he sued like
alex jones and about
people but all he was trying to do the
whole time was get his
frog off of the adl hate list and so
it's like man just see the adl
did you stop seeing everybody else did
you hear that fred perry is going to ban
they're discontinuing the black and gold
shirts because the proud boys wear them
enrique had a good response to that he
was like we should pick his most popular
color and adopt it
and just keep playing like a game of
whack-a-mole how stupid is that oh here
we go
keck mythology look at this keck is the
deification
of the concept of primordial darkness in
the ancient
egyptian uh ag dawg cosmogony
of hemapul hemophilus the ogdode
consisted of four pairs of deities four
male gods paired with their female
counterparts
keck's female counterpart was coquette
cac and coquette in some
some aspects also represent night and
day and were called razor
up of the light and razor up of the
night the name is written as
kk or kkyw with a variant on sky
hieroglyph and
ligature ligature with with the staff
associated with the word for darkness
so wait are they saying that kak is bad
well he's dark
darkness isn't necessarily bad yeah here
we go in popular culture they say uh
in in relation to 2016 presidential
election
individuals associated with online
message boards such as 4chan
noted the similarity between kak and the
character pepe the frog
this combined with the frequent use of
the term cac as a stand-in for the for
slang
lol and they explain some
okay which was often paired with images
of pepe resulted in a resurgence of
interest in the ancient
deity the funny thing is i guess like
what was the the image of kek looked
like someone sitting at a computer
screen
yeah they were so crazy
i think that was fake though was that
fake i don't know i like to believe
yeah i know it's fun to believe but it
is true that there's an ancient god cac
and that keck is like a thing they were
saying and there's a frog
and the egyptians had batteries and
light bulbs and light bulbs according to
hieroglyphics
there's there's all right i'm holding a
giant bulb with looks like a film
side there's a guy holding a battery
behind him there was one thing i saw
that battery the prophecy of cac look at
this
so this this right here you can see
there's a person then there's this thing
whatever that is behind it
and they're like person using a computer
internet meme magic
it's kind of dumb because this squiggly
line they're just like i don't know i
just call it meme magic dna like you
don't know what that is yeah it could be
dna whatever
but it does look like someone's sitting
at a computer they can't
i don't think that's real though i doubt
they had computers
yeah but that's just doubt no i think
somebody made that up
you think they photoshopped it no i
think someone made the symbol of course
i don't know like i'm saying it's not a
real egyptian symbol
i'm curious what it's called i could be
wrong
or trump could be magical and he's gonna
win again as predicted
yeah but uh if if kek is the bad guy if
he's the darkness
well the darkness isn't always bad you
know you can't have the light without
the dark that's how the the theory goes
yeah yeah why is why th the dark is just
an uh uh
i guess a stand-in for bad because we
died at night
it was cold crops wouldn't grow and get
you so visual
right right right rely on light yeah so
like nick probably loves the dark
snake yeah the snakes and the cats they
probably love the dark that's when they
would eat us
no the cats are crepuscular they can see
at night though what do you mean
corpuscular crepuscular they
they come out dawn and dusk that's why
bucco's like sleeping during the show
and he wakes up right when we're done
cause he's like
time to get up it's like you know it's
getting dark out did you did you hear
about those lions in africa there were
like two lions that would they went in
and they ate like everyone in a camp and
they attacked
right at like two in the morning they
were not very crepuscular in that
instance so i think that's why
what do you mean yeah for sure yeah i
mean
but you know it was also like when it
was cold and dark out you couldn't grow
crops
and so people would be like the darkness
is bad and scary and we're gonna die
it's kind of weird though because we
loved looking at the stars so the dark
wasn't
you know really bad i think i i i
wouldn't know enough about religions to
actually
say whether this is true or not but like
the eastern religions probably viewed it
more
balanced like the way you're saying it
and the western seem to view it more
negatively
you know like yin yang light and dark
balanced together
but maybe not you know did did did god
create light and dark yeah
they say in the in genesis so so maybe
it's just people eventually adopted that
as some kind of
you know yeah they were like sun
worshiping relig cults and then they
were like
moon worshipping cults i think the
aryans were moon worshippers they would
come out at night
which is part of why their skin was so
light i think
someone told me that i didn't know that
i mean they were i i
i've heard that they were into like
occult stuff i don't know that's true
the aryans the ancient arians
oh the ancient areas i don't know much
about their history but i heard that no
they were moon dwellers
yeah you got nothing yeah we we just
went off into like crazy
yeah but it's because of cacman so what
does this mean for november 3rd who's
going to win
it's a simulation it's a religion i
don't know what do you think
i don't know is trump gonna win november
third i think that he's gonna win unless
there's
cheating there's they're cheating dude
yeah i think i think they're cheating so
i
it could go either way but i thought
that they were going to cheat and steal
it in 2016
too but they're literally cheating and
we're watching them do it right now yeah
did you see them throw all the all the
ballots away
yeah which which they're saying they're
saying those are old ballots though to
be fair they're claiming that those are
from 2018. did you see
james o'keefe's video what time is it
did you see james o'keefe's video
yeah yeah okay so the dude's driving
around like shaking ballots like look at
this
gonna get paid the night the the
craziest part of all of this
is that the media is like oh they're
spreading conspiracy theories that
there's ballot harvesting and all this
stuff and they're
they're trying to illegitimize the
election and it's like dude you guys
have been trying to legitimize the
election for four years
dude like this whole russia hoax and all
this stuff that you guys have been doing
has been an effort to delegitimize the
election and now you're going to
be like the rights crazy for doing this
that's the game even before the
wikileaks the hillary clinton emails
delegitimized the
democratic national committees yeah they
i mean they were giving the debate
questions to clinton yeah among a bunch
of other really messed up things like
there was it was totally rigged and we
weren't supposed to know about it
but because of wikileaks we do and what
if what if that really is why trump won
like think about it what if they really
why i turned on hillary 100
if i didn't know if i thought she
legitimately got the thing i probably
wouldn't have hated her i definitely
wouldn't have hated her i didn't hate
her
i'd never really liked her what if
that's the one thing the democrats
didn't predict
that someone was going to leak all of
this to wikileaks wikileaks would
publish it
and then all of a sudden you just had
this massive uproar that people couldn't
ignore
and this weird creepy conspiracy stuff
i'll tell you this man
it definitely they're cheating right now
for sure you and i were arguing about
this
what how do you define cheat and we're
like literally looking at the definition
of cheat till
it's deceptively or unfairly you know
give yourself an advantage
that would you agree that's definitely
what they're doing yeah absolutely
they're saying democrats are going to
vote by mail more than republicans
so they're definitely changing the rules
i just got
i opened up instagram and it was like
you live in new jersey
you are going to get a mail a ballot in
the mail whether you asked for it or not
and i'm like oh great then you see this
thing with james o'keefe
where this dude's going around
collecting bouts it's on video
imagine now so so the difference the
thing here is in that election i guess
they did mail in right for the primary
so they sent out all these mail and
bouts then a dude went around collecting
them
and then you have on video other guys
saying they were all blank he's like i
looked at them they were blank
and that's exactly what i and everybody
else was saying was gonna happen
the funny thing about it is james
o'keefe knew the whole time
he just had to get the confirmation and
publish a story now what are they
claiming they're saying
james o'keefe is making it up it's
edited yeah my favorite thing is
the dude on camera who is saying i'm
getting paid and all this stuff
claims it's not his real voice and it's
it's it's dubbed over
you know why that's funny because he's
holding the ballots in his hand
so it's like okay then what were you
saying as you walked around with stacks
of ballots
on twitter he was like thanks for all
the new subs looks like i'm famous
wow and wasn't one of the one of the
people in the video that spoke to james
like one on record
and he's like a smallie community
organizer there was like i think it was
a woman
was it a woman are you talking about
someone else i think it was a man in the
video from last night yeah
there was some guy um he worked in like
the somali community and he was like
going on right now oh right right this
is what
mars people are doing and it's like how
you so you're calling him a liar too
like yep okay this guy was posting on
snapchat like look at all the bouts i
have i'm getting paid for this
yeah so the the defense from the left is
it's not illegal to do that
right he's helping people vote uh did
you skip the part where the guy said the
ballots were blank
and they said who fills them out oh and
almost people
dude the game is rigged man i'm i'm
worried about what's gonna happen if
trump loses after seeing things like
that
because that one video no one's gonna
believe the results
if and and i i don't know man
i mean i wouldn't i'm not gonna believe
it i don't if he loses i'm gonna be like
they cheated
if he if he wins i'm gonna be like they
cheated they're cheating right now we
know they're win or lose they're
cheating so they're gonna mail you a
ballot
yeah and then someone can walk by the
mailbox and take it
yep that's crazy they go so so so think
about all the old people
who get all these ballots and are
probably just not paying attention just
sitting in their house house
think about this what happens if you
never get your ballot what if
what if i never get it and i'm like it's
election day i have no ballot because
someone stole it
then you then then you have no number
you have what do you track you look like
your name maybe you just go number
vote and then they say no you already
voted then are you in trouble for trying
to vote twice
yeah this is why universal
uh mail-in voting is broken and i tell
you man it's the funniest thing when we
see story after story from npr from the
new york times from the baltimore sun
saying straight up
we're straight dump in primary ballots
in the dumpster
because they were that we got them too
late i'm exaggerating but you have all
these stories like baltimore sun saying
70 000 ballots
you know were held for too long through
no fault of their own the voters will be
disenfranchised
then these same organizations say trump
said without evidence that there was
impropriety in mainland voting
it's like you told me that you it's the
it's what the
well you know what i love about the news
is that trump will repeat something they
say and they'll call him a liar
i just i'm just dude
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time